guy millière chercheur au gates tonnes
institute hauteur de après trump aux
éditions balland bonjour 10 milliards
merci beaucoup d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin dans la matinale verte et
france alors on a entendu notre reporter
thomas bonnet nous parler de la réaction
dans les médias américains à dire que
joe biden avait gagné pour mieux pour
vous qui a marqué des points hier lors
de cette rencontre donc pas du tout je
dirais que on a cité d'autres reporter
la cité sionnel qui est très souvent
citée par des journalistes français
il faut savoir que le cnn est une chaîne
qui est très orienté et qui a perdu plus
de 70% de ses téléspectateurs et qui est
en crise c'est parce que si elle est
latente risque de reporter de cnn
commence à poser des questions par
contre un petit peu plus critique que ce
qui a visiblement été trop brutale
mais ce qui doit être dit c'est que joe
biden est arrivé à genève dans une
situation saine blesse et après avoir
cédé il était en situation de faiblesse
parce que il a placé la numérique en
position d'égalité avec lui c'était une
chance inespérée pour vladimir poutine
il est en situation de faiblesse parce
que je dirais que même si ça n'est pas
dit dans la plupart des journaux c'est
quelqu'un qui est atteint de problèmes
de stabilité qui sont très visibles et
je dirais que des gens comme le devinez
qui en ont parfaitement conscience c'est
pour cette raison qu'il n'ya pas d'une
conférence de tester le jeu direct et
une conférence de presse commune qui
n'aurait pas été possible
c'est cette raison qui explique la
conférence de presse qui n'était pas
évident à bhl qui était distingue
justement c'est le problème de 2
répartie peut-être de joe biden oui mais
si vous regardez la conférence de presse
de lundi new kittin de vladimir poutine
a été très à l'aise qu'il a répondu à
toutes les questions n'est pas des
questions préparées à la branche alors
que je dirais si l'on veut garder ce cap
et joe biden il a comme l'a dit
on rapportait lui dix courses sont
élément moteur et ensuite elle a répondu
à des questions posées à l'avance à des
journalistes qui a été choisie en avance
il n'y a pas eu la moindre improvisation
il n'est pas possible de faire une
improvisation des jobs hayden et cela
s'est vu pendant son séjour à londres il
y a eu des moments où il a un peu perdu
ses moyens il ya un peu perdu sur son
discours et puis il faut savoir et je
dirais que la nicotine
on a parfaitement conscience que les
états unis sont en crise sur plusieurs
plans et il faut savoir que les états
dits son tapis ou se sont tenu des
discours extrémistes et vladimir poutine
n'a pas manqué de les citer et d'y
revenir
d'ailleurs les événements au capital de
la dîmière poutine pour répondre à à
dubaï dan qui l'attaquait aussi sur sur
les droits de l'homme on a parlé de
naval oui je vais dire est qu'il par
rapport au capitole d'admirer poutine a
dit il ya des gens qui sont emprisonnés
sans présomption d'innocence depuis plus
de quatre mois alors qu'ils n'ont commis
aucun crime et il a raison de dire une
hyène jeune femme qui est militaire qui
a été acculé par un policier ne tenez
pas l'identité du policier et donc
n'allumez routine a dit tout cela on
crée un rien que ces éléments mais aussi
aux bananes en position de faiblesse je
dirais que en a point de mire un instant
de nordstream bye bye les attirer sur
cette note lahlimi routine peut
considérer qu'il a remporté une grande
victoire
joe biden a cédé sur ce plan nous a dit
que l'acceptation par joe biden devait
des sanctions mises par donald trump sur
le cayston perso l'homme tué moi sur le
nom d'une pipe line est quelque chose de
très important je dirais que c'est
quelque chose qui va renforcer le poids
de vladimir poutine vis-à-vis de
l'europe occidentale c'est quelque chose
qui va rapporter beaucoup d'enfants à la
russie c'est quelque chose qui va donner
de la puissance à la russie c'est
quelque chose qui va priver l'ukraine de
revenus je dirais que c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement important est comme
ça c'est le produit avant la rencontre
je ne vous dirais qu'avant la rencontre
de genève vladimir poutine avait déjà
gagné la rencontre de genève et je
dirais que sur beaucoup de plans john
dryden a fait preuve de faiblesse ont
parlé il ya un stage la liberté cliquer
il ya eu deux attaques très graves
contre des entreprises américains en
termes de si la sécurité les services
américains pensent que cela vienne la
russie je dirais que la ville où tina a
botté en touche n'a pas répondu à la
question mais thomas hayden n'a pas
insisté il a simplement glissé il a
présenté une liste de d'une quinzaine de
sites qu'il ne fallait surtout pas
toucher à qu'est ce que ça veut dire
les deux déjà que les autres secteurs
peuvent s'inquiéter parce que si vous
dites il ya ce secteur qui ne faut pas
toucher que le vacancier des gens qui
travaillent dans les autres secteurs
qu'on peut les toucher
le dire est que cette façon de répondre
d'une façon qui est une façon à 40
je dirais que dans une rencontre
internationale de ce genre il y a des
rapports de force sur ce point la force
était du côté de l'as des meetings c'est
une réalité et je dirais qu'on défend
dans ce genre de relation les intérêts
de son pays qui l'admirent meeting de
quoi qu'on pense à son sujet a défendu
les intérêts de la russie
je ne vois pas en quoi dubaï donne à
défendre les intérêts des états unis
et puis à des sujets qui ont été du tout
abordé la chine l'iran par exemple c'est
d'y aller et venir du milliaire c'est ma
dernière question quel intérêt pour joe
biden doit rencontrer vladimir poutine
finalement est-ce qu'il fallait fixer
finalement les points de crispation pour
mieux combattre la chine c'est la
volonté de joe biden je dirais que pour
le moment vu l'attitude que joe biden a
adopté de nombreuses fois ces derniers
temps il a été une à montrer une forme
d'hostilité la russie ce qui n'est pas
une bonne façon de se rapprocher de la
russie et de la ville ce qui est de la
chine
et je dirais que si je fais le contraste
avec l'attitude de donald trump donald
trump respecter la dignité innée poser
des rapports de force et zodiac ça me
paraît être la bonne façon de faire le
job hayden montrant ni respect une
possibilité de la dernière poutine et se
met en position de faiblesse je veux
dire que les conséquences doivent être
grave et je dirais que manière poutine
est l'allié de l'iran et je dirais qu'il
voie d'eau madden se place en position
de faiblesse
l'avenir note john brennan de retourner
dans l'accord de juillet 2015 modifié
c'est pour ça qu'il ya des discussions à
genève en ce moment dans un film à
vienne
en ce moment je dirais que les
discussions de vienne sont des potions
ou les états unis sont aussi en position
de faiblesse
donc je dirais guy millière merci
beaucoup malheureusement on n'a plus le
temps de poursuivre on reparlera de
l'iran évidemment qu'elles rencontrent
donc qualifiée de constructive
constructive néanmoins pas reparlé de
leader hier
merci beaucoup guy millière pour votre
analyse en direct de los angeles ce
matin
[Musique]